twenty-five of the world's best
professional surfers are converging on
an unusual surf spot this weekend for a
topic competition called the founders
cup it's not happening in Hawaii or
Tahiti but in the middle of California's
inland farm country the contest will
take place on a 14 acre man-made Lagoon
that generates seven foot tall rideable
waves every few minutes its creator
Kelly Slater invited our Carter Evans to
test it out he explained how this could
change the sport forever by bringing it
to landlocked locations it's just
another day at work for eleven time
world champion surfer Kelly Slater
at first glance this could be any one of
Slater's favorite waves around the world
from Australia's Gold Coast to South
Africa's turbulent Indian Ocean Shores
to the faint North Shore of Oahu
but today Slater's riding the surf of
Lemoore California more than 100 miles
inland from the nearest coastline smack
dab in the middle of the state's
agricultural heartland if this same
exact reef and wave was in the ocean I
know it'd be really really crowded every
day every wave is the wave of the day
out here it's all possible thanks to a
decade-long quest by Slater and his team
to build a machine that can produce
7-foot tall
professional-grade artificial waves at
the push of a button wave is launched
the key component is this 100-ton
mechanism that looks like a locomotive
riding alongside this half mile long
pool basically it's a foil that pushes
through the water all the energy is
transmitted into a swell because the
hydrofoil settings are adjustable and
the contours of the pools bottom are
constant this wave introduces something
new to surfing predictability giving
everyone the equal opportunity to
demonstrate what their talents and
skills are it seems a lot more fair
because it is exactly the same every
time almost exactly the same while a
man-made swell adds consistency is it
surfing in my mind no Surfer magazine
editor Justin Houseman says it loses the
essence of the sport as much as riding
the waves is the important part the fact
that you're doing it in an ocean and you
learn how to survive in that ocean and
you learn how to read that ocean that's
what makes surfing fun whether or not
recreational surfers take to it
Slater's wave seems tailor-made for
professional competition and this
weekend it will host its first official
world surf league event but Slater's
ambitions don't end there we feel that
this allows us to go to new Marcus
Sophie Goldschmidt is CEO of the world
surf league which bought Slater's
artificial wave technology two years ago
the league plans to build more of these
facilities all over the world do you see
this technology drawing other people in
perhaps you know a kid from Iowa wants
to be a surfer in a few years he can
because there's one of these nearby
exactly now it makes dreams a reality
but is that your vision to allow more
people to experience I have no problem
with more people experiencing yeah I
don't necessarily want my favorite waves
around the world to get more crowded but
if these are crowded that's so funny how
long you've been serving about 25 years
on this day I was the one crowding his
new favorite wave and despite my
experience I
nervous to surf Kelly Slater's personal
way water there we go I'm gonna make
this Clark seconds later the massive
hydrofoil was slicing through 15 billion
gallons of water and it was time to take
the plunge
I dunno what everyone feels that's why I
enjoy so much when people come here get
nervous and blow their first what if I
should hit like it afterwards I gotta
tell them I did the same thing they're
like no really you know yeah you tackle
some of the most dangerous waves in the
world and yet you still have nerves on
this yeah it's weird it's strange it
doesn't make sense
neither does building a surf break in
the middle of a farmer's field
that didn't stop Kelly Slater from
making it a reality for CBS this morning
Carter Evans labore California Carter
did really well CBS Sports will
broadcast the world surf league's
Founders Cup competition you can watch
this Saturday May 5th at 2:00 Eastern
right here on CBS that is so cool Claire
Evans did more than really well I say
Carter Evans badass on the surfboard you
know I could see if you're a real surfer
you would you prefer to be on the waves
on the ocean yeah but if you're a
beginner and you don't have access to
the weights I think Kelly Slater that's
a very cool if you live in the middle of
the country at least you get to catch
over and that's a very cool